Pop away the days on the 2015 bubble calendar.
After you place the final piece on your 1,000-color
CMYK puzzle.
Because it’s episode 48 of LÜT.
Wake up in mid-air inside a tree tent.
Tentsile portable treehouses combine hammocks
with tents to provide shelter without being
affected by topography, wetness, lumps or
bumps.
Just make sure you’re wearing a sleeping
bag.
Selk’bag is an award-winning sleepwear system
designed to give maximum mobility and comfort
- inspired by Chilean nomads.
No matter what card game you play use this
developer’s code-deck, which includes programming
languages like PHP, CSS and C++.
See plush slippers on your feet, whether they’re
zombie heads, Godzilla feet or Freudian…slippers.
Grizzly bear bean bag, log pillow, meat pillow,
skull chair.
Cherish the human skull with this full-size
cardboard sculpture made out of 50 layers
for you to assemble.
He comes in brown, white, black and zebra,
and his name is Vince.
Convince yourself this candle will have a
treasure inside.
One in fifty PopUp diamond candles contain
a 0.10 carat diamond randomly inserted into
the wax mould by the President of the PopUp
Paris company.
Invite company over and show them your Bucket
Of Doom, a storytelling card game in which
you attempt to escape fatal scenarios using
useless objects…
like “You’ve been buried alive in an airtight
coffin,” and you somehow hatch your escape
using a Didgeridoo.
Do yourself a favor and organize your relatively
dirty desk thanks to this genius paperclip
holder and reinvent your keychain using the
keyport.
A compact device that replaces oddly-shaped
keys with key port blades - so no more key
jingling or scratching.
And you can also include a bottle opener or
flash drive.
Drive mug muggers away by using the plug coffee
mug - which features a removable plug that
renders the mug useless for anyone.
Clampersand.
Clamp clothes like a daredevil by hiring the
Amazing Pegzini Family to employ that old-timey
highwire way to dry laundry.
Water your plants the futuristic way with
Plantui - a soil-free indoor smart garden.
Featuring an intelligent light system and
automatic watering pump to grow herbs, salad
greens and edible flowers all year round.
So you have plenty of Thyme.
To solve your crossword puzzle clock.
Cross homemade twinkies off your to do list
and add some personality with Edible Eyes.
That feature 10 different expression per pack.
Then pack your skull and bones claw for a
neverending trip into the Infinite Dungeon
Corridor, a medieval spin on the infinity
mirror that showcases a torch-lined corridor
that stretches on forever.
But before you go - learn a bit about the
stars above by studying the Know Your Stars
UniqCube.
And once you’re able to recognize Telescopium
from Aries, you’re ready to tell the world:
That’s it.
I’m off to otter space.
And as always - thanks for watching!
Encase your brain in Vsauce with official
Vsauce beanies from Beardo.
Just make sure you add the code “VSAUCE”
to get 50% off.
Which is like half off.
It's like 50%.
Man.